On June the 23rd Britain's go to the
polls to vote on whether to remain in
the European Union or to leave it one of
the most momentous decisions the country
has faced in the last 40 years one of
the key drivers in the exit or brexit
campaign is the UK Independence Party or
UK and my guest is Diane James one of
the party's vice chairs and one of its
any peas
why should British voters take a leap
into the darkness with a party like hers
Dyanne James welcome to conflict zone
thank you
we're in the final straight before the
referendum the latest average of six
polls from May the 17th of May the 25th
has the remain camp on 53% and leave on
47 clear to be losing the argument well
the polls when it got it completely
wrong for the United Kingdom general
election that's been acknowledged
worldwide today and in terms of those
polls I'm still a great believer that
there is everything to play for and the
the sort of poll data that I'm more
interested in is the ones that put us
absolutely Nick and Nick with a smile if
you're so confident why are you already
talking about what will happen if you
lose Nigel Farage the other day said in
the 52 to 48 referendum this would be
unfinished business by a long way if the
remain camp wins two-thirds to one-third
that ends it so he's already talking
about a situation in which you lose know
what he's very confident is it what he
is doing is very cleverly motivating and
assuring that those are people that
actually want to get the United Kingdom
out of the European Union now reminded
of the the importance of making their
visit to the polling stations and
getting that eggs and the right fat
place on the ballot playing what is
actually saying is that we're going
having referenda will do pushing
referenda that's what he's actually
there's two points there isn't there
first of all we've got David Cameron the
United Kingdom prime minister saying
absolutely no there is no second
referendum that's the first I think
marker in the sand the more important
marker in the sand was something whether
he wins or loses they that would the
more important marker in the sand was
the mention in the Strasbourg Parliament
at a recent plenary session when the
head of the greens group a German lady
buy them by the way announced that
referenda should be banned in EU Member
States because they were too dangerous
to the European but she doesn't have any
say in what and you know that she was
directly referring to the recent
referendum in the Netherlands on the
Ukraine agreement so there was a German
any
hey over here over there when it comes
to the British referendum as well you
know you're just preparing to be bad
losers and keep on calling for I don't
happen to drink but I've got the bottle
of champagne ready for because I think
it will be a good result I think it
would be very very close I'm quite happy
to to give ground on that point in the
meantime though you're getting very
jittery I'm thinking of the Institute
for Fiscal Studies when they came out a
few days ago with the warning of the
consequences of a British exit and you
sat on them there was this hysterical
response to them from Nigel Faraj saying
they take direct funding from the
European Union and the government all
their friends are cheating in this
referendum by selling this constant
negative message why is a jittery again
if your champagne is on ice I wouldn't
call it jittery I think that Nigel was
right to point out that there is vested
interest in the vast majority of bodies
that are coming out
linking very clearly and clearly to the
project fear strategy that David
Cameron's government has launched and he
was just reminding people quite gently
but also with a degree of a force that
you know
wait a minute just can factor in where's
the vested interest and you know we went
on to issued lots of data pointing out
the level of you you funding for a whole
number of organizations that have
suddenly jumped on this bandwagon but
it's a bit rich for you to criticize the
Institute for Fiscal Studies now when
the same body the IFS accused the major
parties of failing to tell the whole
truth about their spending plans last
year you were all over them you were
crying what a great organisation it was
you were even tweeting out their
findings so just because they happen to
come out with one that disagrees with
you then they're rubbish then they're
owned by somebody else well then it's
all the big cheat no it's not a big
treat it was an opinion it was not would
you mind if I just made a point that we
can use yeah very quickly if the Office
of Budget Responsibility which is meant
to be the neutral organization here in
the United Kingdom aside from the
Treasury which is a government arm if
they were to come out with some of the
data then I think that would be a
more plausible well you all have a
chance to talk about a little because
okay but but I don't know how you expect
to unify the brexit side the side that
wants to get out of the European Union
when you're so divided amongst
yourselves you seem to be fighting
almost like ferrets in a sack we have
this vitriol from one of exit campaign
to another exit campaign Nigel Farage on
May the 20th spoke of the Cretans in
charge of vote leave and accused them of
bad-mouthing him parent banks of leave
you said of the other brexit team I
wouldn't put them in charge of the local
sweetshop how do you expect to unify a
British public to your point of view
when you're so disunited you're hardly
in agreement we're not just united I'm
this evening speaking at yet another
debate just like all of my MEP
colleagues just like lots of you keep
activist councillors I didn't make the
mark no but we're we're sharing the
stage I just remember that politics has
entered into the scenario of
entertainment everyone respects us well
that's why we have programs TV programs
now some words that are anymore it's
just entertainment you wanna keep the
crowds of music it catches the attention
even you've picked up on it so I've got
no issue with this I've got none
whatsoever
there's been no retaliation it's it but
it is causing exactly what we want which
is lots of interest gaining people's
interest and ensuring that they're
actually looking at what the subject
matter more to remain well I don't agree
with that we started that failure at
that point your party has consistently
tried to escape the label of being a
racist party hasn't it we are not and we
never will be that's what your leader
says yes some of the polls tell a very
different story don't they
a YouGov survey in February last year
reported that around half of you get
voters say they are prejudiced against
people of other races only 49% said they
were not prejudiced 42% of your party
supporters admitted to being a little
prejudiced while 6%
so there were very prejudiced you're
happy to provide a political home for
people with those views just look at the
advert that the remain campaign which is
village just deal with this well the
issue that you're raising I don't know
where you've got your data from you guys
okay I've got no it's a polling me for
instance
TNS data a respected market research
company a company that doesn't have a
political affiliation that is not linked
in terms of their interests and their
support for a particular political party
I'm gonna eat this up no one knows him
they've made it up but doesn't it seem
like they client I'm asking how you feel
could you just remind me when the data
was taken it was February last year for
February 2015 in the run-up to the
general election when you Kip was under
the most ferocious attack from the
Conservatives in particular but also
from other political parties and they
were trying at it with every means and
you've given us some brilliant examples
to label us as racist and homophobia and
they really did throw the book at us do
you buy into the idea that the EU is
some kind of rotting corpse that we need
to get away from in Britain the British
people need to get away from
well you've used the phrase rotting
corpse I wouldn't use it that I would
say it's a concept from one of your
Emmys well maybe thank you you want you
direct the question at me I'm responded
by saying I wouldn't describe the EU as
a rotting corpse personally I would
describe it as an organization that's
run out of steam compared to its
original concept one that does need
radical reform which it's not able to
invest in and and make the necessary
changes to make it accountable make it
value for money and make it stand up on
the global global platform that on that
basis for me it's a failure yes it's a
failure but it contains eight of the 20
most competitive economies in the world
that's not a hallmark of
well it is when you compare France and
Italy which were effectively economic
basket cases and Greece as well but
eight of the 20 most competitive
economies in the world and you still say
it's it's it's it's a basket case no no
I'm what I am saying
I'm just challenging you back because
you've given me a phrase and you're
using one description which is their
competitive saying it's on the way out
yeah sorry I'm saying the EU is yes I'm
saying your point was that they are
competitive I'm saying
that I if they were economically
positive and economically viable that
would be a more important measure but if
they were why would they attract ever
greater flows of foreign investment from
Japan from China from India and the
United States their percentage
investment flow into Europe has gone
from 20% in the 1950s 55 Japan China
what the eight states that are in the
twenty Belgium Denmark Finland UK Sweden
Netherlands Germany and Luxembourg those
are the eight states okay thank you very
much yeah but you didn't know that no I
wanted to know these figures from the
world economic I I gave you four and I
wanted to hear who the other four was
and they were shall we say a smaller
Member State there may be well hardly
Germany no I put Germany when it was one
of the biggest is put countries such as
Finland and Belgium is what I was
referring to but it doesn't change the
point that eight out of the EU countries
are in the twenty most competitive yeah
and one of the big issues is hardly an
organization that's going down no but
one of the big issues that mister
Yonkers got and the whole EU concept has
got is this risk of contagion and what
they fully recognize is the the number
of countries that were thought
effectively a big euro skeptic component
no matter whether some of those and
Germany is a prime example very
successful economically although there
is some data today in the in the media
that's suggesting maybe that dream is
going out of it going out the window
but the point I'm making is that this
issue if they let the United Kingdom go
with a very very vibrant mark market
with a free man
kit approach compared to many of the
other European states what then happens
let's look at what then happens because
one of the accusations against the leave
side is that you consistently fail to
articulate what the British economy
would look like after brexit last
December we got a flash of real honesty
from Nigel Farage at the Oxford Union
when he said that I will accept that
none of us knows what the risks are if
we leave the European Union marvellous
the most momentous decision that the
British are being required to take in 40
years sort of fly with me and we'll see
what happens don't think the country is
worth more than they their whole point
is if we put the X in the Box in the
right box on the ballot paper we then
have two years of hopefully a
responsible government hopefully a
responsible team that will negotiate a
an exit package which is sure hopefully
is a big word it's like surely isn't it
maybe yes this is a huge gamble you want
it's a huge gamble for both sides this
government here in the United Kingdom
have not responded to what about the
issues about the eurozone what about the
issues with the European Central Bank
what about the issues with the euro
European Investment loan portfolio and
all of the dangers that are coming down
the line from just those three areas I
want to know what since when did your
clairvoyant abilities qualify you to ask
Britain's to take this huge step into
the unknown yeah but isn't it now you
don't have any you you have a leader
who's tried seven times to get elected
to the bar at Westminster and failed I
have to say my career to date is not
included being a clairvoyant you're
quite right
I'm a member of the European Parliament
what I do is voice and vert and
verbalize as much as I can
the issues that arise in Strasbourg and
in Brussels I try and get those covered
in the media in the press here in the
United Kingdom to really really
highlight which I'm a media sometimes
doesn't take sufficiently result of what
is wrong with the whole European Union
concept now what we've been able to do
during this campaign is give example
after example actually inform the public
so it's all very well project fear
saying oh my goodness you know these
going to help come on to your project a
little later let's come to figures yes I
know you like figures because you said
the EU referendum deserve to be decided
on facts and not fear that's something
that you actually said yeah this claim
that 350 million is what Britain's cents
to the EU every week so Andrew dilma
chair of the UK statistics authority and
probably think he's just a another sham
part of another sham organisation he
wrote in February that this statement
was potentially misleading he says there
was a lack of clarity in the way the
official statistics had been drawn on in
the statements he considered in
particular I note the use of the 350
million pound figure which appears to be
a gross figure and doesn't take into
account the rebate or other flows from
the EU to the UK public sector or flows
to non public sector bodies so he's
telling you your figure doesn't hold up
okay
the figure is has been used and is being
used by vote leaf which is the official
designated leave organisation in this
referendum
I had matter does it he's saying it's a
rubbish I have made the point and I made
the point at a debate last night that I
didn't agree with that figure I will now
give you my view on it I think it's a
complete under estimate because what it
does it takes out if you like out that
one big contribution and it then removes
an element of rebate but not sufficient
it divides it by the number of days in a
year and it comes up with a figure now
even further than hundred he says the
amount the Treasury ream it's the
brussels and thus the direct cost to UK
taxpayers always has the rebate deducted
before payment is made because of this
the correct figure taking into account
the
should be around 280 million a week I've
got 70 million lower than the one that
your campaign is no it's the campaign as
I just mentioned it's a figure launched
by vote Nigel Farage has used the leader
of your party okay
well I'm using the figure of sir you say
he's wrong thank you for informing me
that Nigel's using the 350 million I'm
using the 280 million figure as a
minimum in terms of the cost of EU
membership because what I'm saying to
people at the debates where I'm a
speaker is this big big difference
between fixed costs and it yeah fixed
costs and indirect an indirect 50
million figure doesn't hold up they
shouldn't be used and Andrew doughnut
was right to question it I'll give you
ground on that yes thank you thank you
let's look at taking back control
because this is one of your big themes
is how much control do you want to take
back I'm thinking of all the hundreds of
treaties that Britain has already signed
how many of those do you want to tear
which a lot of them give away some
sovereignty you'd accept that I mean
look at look at NATO for instance who's
the supreme Allied commander in NATO is
America so American who can tell us to
go to war or control our soldiers if we
go to war you want to get out of NATO
I'd like to get out of article 42
you're asking my you asked me which
articles in terms of EU membership I
would like to I'm asking I'm asking
there was a first question which was
which articles would you like to get out
of in terms of EU membership now give
you one example which is article 42
you've then moved on to the link between
defense and NATO and the reason I've
cited article 42 is that's the one
associated with EU defence obligations
as a Member State no I don't want to get
out of they you know I'm so not prepared
to cede some sovereignty to NATO we
seeded sovereignty to NATO when we
joined NATO yes see there's my
sovereignty to the EU no we did not
no we did not we see
we joined a trade organization now this
referendum in a few weeks time I will it
will also be my first referendum but in
talking to my my mother my father's not
around I asked her the question when you
voted in the referendum in the 1970s
what were you voting on and she said I
was voting for a common market I was
voting for a trade association and she
is of all representative of generations
who believed that all they were doing
was voting for to become a member of a
trade so you don't get out of NATO do
you want to belong to the WTO in future
we would take up a place on the WTO yes
quite the fact that the head of the WTO
says it would have to be renegotiated
with 162 countries we have a trade
agreement we don't have any trade
agreements with the United States but we
trade with the United States and so I
just okay I know the head of the WTO is
saying if there's brexit you would have
to renegotiate your membership of the
WTF where hundred and sixty two
countries
I'm delighted I'm delighted to take
lessons from the head of the WTO I will
happily go and now read what you just
explained to me and I'll be able to come
into the future stage but I'm just
fascinated that here's another
individual telling us as an external
body why don't we get that sort of
absolutely honest information with the
necessary details from our own
government representative our own
elected MP and effectively our own
business department let's go back to two
facts war laws for instance Nigel Faraj
told CNN February 18th this year that
75% of the laws in Britain and now made
by the institutions of the European
Union you go along with it
I certainly go along with it it's a
figure in that region yes because it
turns out that figure comes from a
mistaken interpretation by a former
senior European official
it was pointed out by channel 4 that you
decided to stick with the bogus figure
even though the mistake was pointed out
to you according to the House of Commons
library in 2010 between 15 and 50
percent of UK legislation comes from the
EU depending on how its measured
European center of Policy Studies says
that only 6.8 percent of UK primary
legislation and 14.1 percent of UK
secondary legislation has passed in
order to implement EU laws so your
figure is way ahead of anybody else's
figure why is that
Jumaane high aren't respond initially
with an anecdote will you allow me to do
that I'd much prefer you'd answer the
question it may be a difficult question
it's not a difficult question all I was
about to say was that as an elected mep
as somebody who sits in the plenary
sessions in both strasbourg and brussels
i watch the decisions being made
i see some of the potential legislation
coming through and then I watch a matter
of months later some form of legislation
being enacted or discussed or being
proposed here in the United Kingdom I'm
able to make that direct link you have
given me quite rightly organizations
that are saying pinpoint absolutely
pinpoint where does that come from I'm
nowhere near your figures are you
agreeing with the figure accepting the
corrections no I'm designing I'm
sticking with a figure well over 70%
under well over 70% I'm not quite I'm
gonna so at least 20% more than the
house Thomas Library was well over the
75 I'm going to say I agree with the
figure over 70% because I look at what
comes out at Her Majesty's Government to
me as an elected official representing
this country and I look at that data
that tells me what Her Majesty's
Government is having to enact given
decisions made in Brussels and
Strasbourg one of the key planks of the
exit campaign that Nigel ferocious
spoken of he says that Turkey is the
single biggest reason
leaving the eu-turkey and the fact that
it may at some point join the EU
although the leave camps ad says in
crimson danger red turkey populations 76
million is joining the EU
that's a misleading ad isn't it I don't
and i'll joining now they're not doing
next week next month they're not joining
next year they may never join at all
they don't need to now look at what
they've achieved so the ad is even more
misleading no no it's not they were if
you again you know I may be teaching you
to suck cakes and that's just an English
phrase for which I apologize but again
if you look back over the last few years
again you look at the plenary sessions
you will see various updates on member
states sorry states countries that want
are seeking member state status and they
go through a series of process series of
steps towards a process and toward an
end point and Turkey is one of those yes
now no it's there's so much opposition
to you no you don't happen to point out
that any of the 28 countries in the you
could veto turkeys membership okay okay
okay Cyprus good Germany has already
said it's against human mission for
Turkey yes so why keep it a project fear
add from your side it's very scared
that's what the implication of this ad
is because turkeys joining the EU it
isn't joining the EU and the ad is wrong
I think the I will go on record as
saying I believe Turkey will join the
European Union
it doesn't need to even begin to comply
with some of the issues that were set
out in terms of his accession because
it's managed to hold the European Union
to ransom over the migration crisis
beautifully done
look at what they've achieved by the end
of June if the agreement goes through if
it's already falling apart
it's not falling apart you give me the
absolute data from the European Union
give me the wording that says turkey has
failed with mrs. Merkel and mr. Erdogan
are still playing language he's taking a
petition very hard line
I'm not going to comply and she's saying
hold on
do you want the euros or don't you want
James yes they're playing language I
think you're playing language - thank
you for being on the conflict zone thank
you very much thank you too